he's mr. Anderson on ballers and right
now playing dr. Aaron Glassman on the
most-watched drama on television on ABC
the good doctor season 1 just concluded
season 2 already renewed great to see
you Richard Schiff wearing that Yankee
cap I like it always wearing a Yankee
cap with pride right now once wore to
the Emmys in 2001 now come on now what
do you mean well I was nominated I had
won the year before for the west wing
for the west wing and pretty sure I
wasn't gonna win again and I had tickets
in Phoenix that you know the World
Series and the Emmys coincided because
of the delay from because of 9/11 right
and I had tickets to Game six and seven
in Phoenix for the World Series against
the Diamondbacks the Yankees took the
three and the three greatest games ever
played in the World Series in New York
as I was working so I couldn't go to
that that was Jeter's mr. November me
that's right uh-huh and and Brosius hit
went out to and I think in the ninth
inning and um and we got blown away
Pettitte remember was tipping pitches it
turned out revealed later in Sports
Illustrated
we lost 16 to 3 in game six and I had
tickets to Game seven which was the
night of the Emmys so I told the
producers of The West Wing I'm going in
Game seven I'm not gonna go to the Emmys
hmm and they said ok and then they gave
me a 6:00 a.m. call time on Monday we
had driven to Phoenix so I wasn't gonna
make it back on time because it's 12
hour drive showed you so I went to the
Emmys and showed up in a Yankee hat with
the stars and stripes in the end wine
right I remember that and that's what I
wore and we're sitting with the soprano
people were all neat Yankee fans so
during the game he made the stage
manager was wearing a Yankee hat turn on
the game during the commercials so I got
to see Soriano's home run and then
backstage ran backstage after we won
best show and found a green room and
watched Mariano strike out a guy to know
what inning would I thought the game was
over he was he was the eighth inning I
was there I was there behind home plate
covering it for ESPN sitting next to my
at the time fiance who was covering my
wife Susie was covering the
for Fox Sports and we were sitting there
after Rivera struck out the side in the
eighth inning Richard fans and the
Diamondbacks were crying they were
crying even wives player wives we were
sitting in that area they were crying
because they knew Rivera the great
Mariano had shown up and it was going to
be a foregone conclusion in the ninth
and yet that did not happen and yet by
the way
Gonzalez's hit still hasn't left the
infield so I was like let's be clear you
know it wasn't tainted when but they
didn't know people got the only real hit
in that inning and when Mariano missed
on the bunt the second base yeah and
pulled Jeter off I still think Jeter
could have kept his foot on pace look at
you but but remember the fans in Arizona
got really hyped up in the top of the
ninth when Randy Johnson came in I'm
just striking out Yankees they got
really loud I remember seeing a shot of
Mariano first time I've ever seen him
look worried and and I think he was just
exhausted because he was pitching too
many I wanted who was this a setup man
you know one I it was a Stanton
[Music]
Mendoza Ramiro Mendoza Mendoza who was
unhittable in that postseason and I
wanted him to come in in the eighth
you're second-guessing Torre in it I'm
still angry were you alone in that green
room order some of the soprano scales
come with you - no I was alone and after
Mariano struck out the guy in the 8th
inning I went yeah and turned around and
realized for four minutes I was blocking
these two people sitting on the couch
who said nothing and it turned out to be
Rob Reiner and Mary Tyler Moore and my
first thought was I should IID I grew up
watching you guys on Saturday night I
since later worked with Rob and told him
the story but um and I was gonna tell
Mary Tyler Moore I think you were my you
know my save you know you were the best
thing when I was young and then I
realized I have gray hair and I'm gonna
make her feel like she's a hundred and
twelve right so that's rude and I just I
just walked out I just say
an apology X I didn't say anything I
just felt so bad that's my test watched
it on some other watch the horror on
some other TV Richard Schiff here on the
Rich Eisen show are you at all concerned
Boone we didn't discuss this on the show
today
but Aaron Boone said he's thinking of
dropping Giancarlo Stanton down in the
order he has just been awful ever since
he had that two home run game obviously
had one in the panic move
well it's April 18th no no they look bad
they look bad and they've looked bad
since midway through spring training
I'll turn off my phone no problem um you
know they started out nine and one in
spring training
and then they started coasting along
right the Red Sox started out mediocre
and that sort of winning everything in
spring training and that's continued
into the season and I I wonder about
Aaron Boone is anyone else yeah a lot of
people in New York are like him to be
the manager for the next 15 years you
would well if they're playing for the
first 15 games you like they play
[Laughter]
Stanton's gonna be fine but I don't like
three righties in a row I all who would
have a similar swing and can be beaten
with similar pitches so a pitcher with a
good outside low slider horse or a
splitter if he gets into his own
pitching against these guys he can get
them all out I want to see didi I want
to see bird come back and break up that
three writers in a rockets they're
worried about standing in the long I
guess that would be the the idea about
it but it has been a difficult start and
I do wonder even because I wanted his
binder to be thrown off of a cliff never
to be seen again I do wonder if Girardi
would have gotten this team off to a
better start
I do think about that you have to assume
that that he would his preparation was
you know bar none I mean he was very
thorough as a manager I don't see the
moves I don't see the pitching moves
being all that different but the
pictures don't seem ready
their bullpen was supposed to be the
greatest in the history of baseball as
an ER a of about six
and they're getting killed and they look
bad in the field there is something
about what what's happening there they
don't look ready to win and maybe it's
an there another year away Richard
Schiff here on the Rich Eisen show the
good doctor is exploded did you guys on
the set see the possibility that you
could be the number one drama on
television when you're doing that really
I don't honestly I don't really think
about that that much and I just like to
do the work and see what happens but in
this day and age of social media because
the response come so quickly
right I was aware of the response very
quickly and I was surprised to be honest
I was I didn't like you know clearly
after the last election I can't predict
American tastes so I but I I was you
know very pleasantly surprised that I
didn't really think much about it I
thought I would do fine mmm I didn't
think it was gonna be a you know a bust
but I didn't know it being the number
one sensation I mean it's basically the
good doctor this is us at the network or
must be because between Freddie and I
one of us is really cute is that what I
could be could be one of those things we
know what that is
how he enjoying ballers - I love doing
ballers I absolutely have a blast last
year especially the last season three
and this is the way the storyline turned
upside down the way the rock and Rob
Corddry and I became kind of a family
and then Webber came along Steven Weber
is my brother the battling brothers I
had a blast this year I been busy so I
can only I could only do two but just
going back on the set and just having
fun and doing what we want and improving
and and Duane DJ or the rock however you
how do you how do what how do you refer
to die no I I think I call him Dwayne
but most people call him DJ mm-hmm and
um he's sweetest guy on earth I mean
he's just phenomenal did you do whatever
he wants right now gets up at 4:00 in
the morning works out for two and a half
hours does three hours of business and
then it comes to set for a 1012 hour a
day pretty remarkable that's that's your
schedule isn't it maybe take that you
didn't take that from the richard schiff
o'clock in the morning
I'm working out my dreams nice that's
bad they're hoping for a Yankee victory
I know what do you think the Giants
should do second overall I love the idea
of a dominant running back because takes
care you know their defense which hasn't
been awful although statistically I
think two years ago they were dreadful
huh but they got they got players I
don't know what they're doing with that
jump here Paul now but um but their
defense has been pretty good but they've
been on the field they're you know 35 to
40 minutes a game why because the Giants
have not had a running game in years now
so the idea of a dominant running back
along with Beckham and maybe I don't
think dad's car that could watch revenge
how else can you I hear you about
revenge but I mean I think they already
have Odell figuring trying to figure him
out what to do with him then to bring
des in in the mix to Sterling Shepard is
no joke chef is good right so he's
terrific on the end and Evan Engram last
year really they barely scratched the
surface with him I think he's gonna have
a nice leap for I I would love if say
Quan Barkley went to New York City it
looks like they'll take a quarterback I
don't know really yeah see this official
know the official opinion if it is not
sir
it would be a seismic event a seismic
sports event and and you don't think the
Giants need to take a quarterback I
think that Eli Manning with say Kwan
Berkeley and Odell Beckham and Sterling
Shepherd and Evan Engram and Nate solder
who they just signed to protect his
blindside from New England to protect
his blindside Eli Manning has at least
two three if not four good years left in
him
and figure out who could be draft at the
top of the second or third round if they
already don't like this kid from Kalin
David Falls when it becomes you
that would be it you know that's
entirely possible to it's entirely
possible to I I think say Kwan Barclays
the play I said that when did I say that
Chris Brockman I said it at the combine
I said it I said it after after the we
saw the second overall figuring that we
get the marriage on the phone now and
just make it official well you know yes
we can okay
good to see you Richard thanks for
coming come back any time my pleasure
you got it Richard Schiff here on the
Rich Eisen show check out the good
doctor when it comes back on ABC TV and
on on HBO ballers
good to see you buddy thank you you got
it Richard Schiff the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience